if you were to look at people who quote
achieve a lot it's not that they're
actually moving faster so first
obviously you need to do stuff but I
think if you're a part of this community
doing stuff isn't really the limiting
factor it's the stuff we're doing which
is the limiting factor the stuff that I
want to do is the stuff that has the
highest leverage and I Define leverage
as the difference between what you put
in and what you get out doing things
that you can cut once sell a thousand
times just thinking how can I get more
back for the time I'm putting in it's
kind of been the core question I've
tried to answer every day which is like
is there a higher and better use of the
time that I have